i called the the pin you win did you
really and uh well yeah but first off i
think bring that up you know i think
she's pretty cute so i'm gonna go for it
oh yeah second off uh
you know i like both of those chicks
though it was it wasn't because of the
personalities or anything that i picked
pena i picked pena because she had beat
i believe katzengano and kat zingano
uh beat amanda and she didn't it wasn't
a fluke win when right when katzengano
beat amanda it was dominate domination
of wrestling and superior ground work
and so you get one ground fighter who's
already beat this chick and then
somebody comes and beats the chick who
beat her right at what she beat her at
ah and so in my head i'm thinking she's
going to get her to the ground and beat
her he's going to get her ground and
beat her and i didn't put no money on it
though because i always [ __ ] lose if
i put money down i don't ever do it i've
only actually i never even put money
down one time i put a weed bet yeah i
bet my buddy a quarter a weed on a fight
and then uh
yeah
and then he's all stoned and you're not
that's right brother well he shared it
with me a little bit
it's all good but the worst is when you
lose a wee bet and your buddy just
smokes it on you got to just sit there
and look at his ass like he's just been
like he's just been eating ghosts bro my
dude my buddy gets so [ __ ] up when we
were younger bro look he looked like
he'd eat a couple damn human this couple
damn ghosts was in him bro he looked
[ __ ] haunted dude he got so hot one
time his [ __ ] dad came to pick him up
and he didn't even know his dad bro and
he [ __ ] fought him right there in the
yard
and he fought him bro like it was
somebody coming to kidnap him
i'd do that right now
but dude fighting your own dad just
because you high or like are you so high
bottom because i'm pissed off and i
don't care if i'm high or what the [ __ ]
dude i just beat his ass just for some
child support yeah yeah let's go son
yeah they should have if a dad flakes on
the kid they should have at least a
couple rounds of when the child's 16 or
over that they got to do in the yard
legally yeah that's right that's that's
what i'm saying that should be part of
the jurisdiction baby let's go dude we
should we got to rewrite some of these
laws man absolutely they got some soft
laws out there let's go through the last
minute this i'll say this man so i'm
sitting over there
and man uh
nunes this looked so much bigger yeah
did it
here's the thing though brother it's
like do no audio is it it don't always
come to your favor when you're when
you're bigger like that that means you
cut more weight and she's a power
puncher right so it's like okay so
you're talking about power puncher who
cuts a lot of weight yeah i bet she's
gonna be great in the first round right
she's a power puncher who cuts a lot of
weight she finds somebody 10 15 pounds
smaller and she hits twice as hard now
what do you think when when you start to
see this happening what would you have
done different here if you're uh
if you're newness
okay i'm noon as first off round one
that's where she made the mistake she
she come out like she's gonna knock her
out in the first round
throwing the power punches she should
have barely won round one i'm serious i
mean she should have gone out there
saying i'm not gonna knock this girl out
yeah i'm gonna barely win round one oh
and then i'm gonna win round two a
little bit better
and i'm gonna win round three a little
bit about round four and five i don't
even give a [ __ ] i already won the fight
i'm just gonna do what i can do now you
know what i'm saying but i think that
she went in there um
she blasted all of her cannons right off
the initial exchange because she was so
used to that you think absolutely when
it works so long you know what i'm
saying it's uh
it works you know if ain't broke don't
fix it but she ran into a different
stylistic matchup here's the thing about
um when she fought rousey
rousey's a great ground fighter in my
opinion rousey is uh probably the best
uh woman ground fighter that there is
out there um actually if rousey and pina
get into it in a ground fight well first
off that'd be sexy but second off
second off um
second ryan's sitting in the front row
because i don't want to spend some time
on myself you know i want a little
camouflage baby yeah well second off i
think that rousey will probably win
eventually because of the submissions
against pena against opinion but here's
the
thing rousey could not get amanda to the
ground you know what i'm saying um she
has that straight up kind of grab him
and clinch style
pina has a style where it's like shoot
under and grab the legs which works
amazing if you're talking about a power
puncher right because a power puncher
when you swing you open up all the
openings for that
like when a mother when i'm fighting a
power puncher i'm i'm not thinking i
hope he don't swing hard i'm thinking i
hope he swings as hard as he [ __ ] can
shoot and get them legs now if you're
ronda rousey
you don't go for the legs she don't do
singles and doubles she has to go
against her opponent in a straight line
that's where she [ __ ] up with amanda
nunez bro she tried to just close that
distance without any type of entangling
in the hands no distractions no nothing
she didn't reach the hands she just
tried to go straight at her and just
like a train but if you would have seen
rousey get amanda to the ground you
probably would have seen even
even
more disparity yeah just like the
disparity was on the feet it had been
the same on the ground she just never
had the
uh
she don't go for those legs you know and
amanda she opens up and throws those big
punches that's when the legs are open
and do you think that's kind of what she
saw because will you play that back
again right opinion lured her into
that's what pena did she she took some
of her best shots lured her in landed
just enough to piss her off and make her
want to hit her more and that's when she
got in on that takedown
i'm pretty sure she shot a double leg i
can't remember though did she shoot a
double i mean she's staying in i
could've sworn she got her to the
and you could tell her nuna is like how
is this not working
and right
and you just stayed right in there just
take i mean you could see it like what
is this hitting right right and you're
absolutely right she just stayed right
in there and now she's advancing forward
right so now she's got a game plan huh
and gets her to the fence here comes a
double if i'm her i'm shooting you'd
already shot
i might have but she was laying in there
too i just i'm curious how she got her
down i'm almost certain she got her legs
oh she tripped her okay there you go
and and nunes is cooked here
yeah but this ain't her this ain't her
game plan she i mean think about
probably been five years at least since
she's been in that position in a fight
bro at least five did she when she
choked when it wasn't a choke right it
was a neck what would it what was the
well it was go back to that last few
seconds there it was probably a choke as
well but
if it wasn't on the throat you could
still choke somebody right here on the
face in the nose
yeah what does she have or you can't
really
maybe she is under
there man well it looked like she was up
on her nose in her mouth but i don't and
it didn't look like she was on the neck
to me either you know but that was a
shock
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one
you